[Music]
my next guest is a comedian who was
making his late-night debut with us this
evening he'd be seen live at the nine
one eight comedy club in Washington DC
January 11th and 12th news welcome very
funny Dan Soder how are you guys look
you guys know about me I am 29 years old
and I am officially a part of the worst
generation of all time we did seriously
if you're under 30 you and I are slowly
ruining everything we ruined the tattoo
you're a white guy under 25 and you're
covered in tattoos I'm probably not
afraid of you that's not how that's
supposed to work if you're over 70 and
you have tattoos I am terrified of you
if I see an old man with a faded anchor
on his forearm no thank you
that's a man that's watched death tell
me I'm supposed to be afraid of some 19
year old arm covered in seaweed tattoos
taking an hour to explain what's on his
body well life's a journey and that's
why I have a koi fish because it
symbolizes peace
shut up Caleb no one cares glad you guys
agree don't you guys know about my
backstory I am the product of a single
parent and whenever it's said like that
always means single mom always cuz no
one [ __ ] about being raised by a
single dad you can't it looks so much
fun playboys all over the house you get
to eat waffles for dinner watch rated R
movies on a school night you're
basically just like a mini wingman the
whole time that's up your dad takes you
out he's like do something cute so pops
can get some strange I like where your
head's at old man I was raised by a
single mom which basically meant I
ruined most of the 80s for her I know
what dating was it was five when my mom
started dating some guy would come over
I'd be like cool a new roommate don't
touch my stuff by the time I was seven I
was like a grizzled veteran I was the
one answering the door smoking a Winston
just all confident like what's up chief
you here for the old lady
right on
quick secret you buy a ninja turtle toy
I'll go get lost in that garage for a
nap I got a lot of free toys it was
awesome I currently live in New York
City which is uh yeah you know it's
there I've been living in New York about
six years now and when I first moved
there I had a huge fear I was gonna get
mugged constantly like every time I left
the house I was like here it comes
someone's gonna take everything I got
over my fear because I learned a trick
and now I use this trick all the time
whenever I think someone might try to
beat me up or mug me I fake a Russian
accent you're welcome it's genius I'll
be walking home late at night too
dangerous looking thugs walk up to me
like yo man you know a neighborhood
y'all ready
you think this bad neighborhood
[Applause]
welcome to the scariest white people
I've owned it I'm so scared of them that
I guarantee you if I was lost
dangerously lost there is no way I'd ask
for Russian for directions
just real quick like sir help me please
help me
how do I get to the subway this subway
walk down Street and throw him :
yes screw that I think I'm just going to
stay lost
[Applause]